was ist das erste was du morgens machst
wenn ich morgens aufstehe dann hole ich
zuerst meine tageszeitung
ich gehe unter die füße
wenn ich aufstehe strecke ich mich ich
ziehe meine hausschuhe an
wenn ich morgens aufstehe schaut euch
das erste handy als erstes mache ich mir
einen frisch gebrühten kaffee ich trinke
meinen kaffee trinke meinen tee wenn ich
morgens aufstehe dann gehe ich als
erstes ins bad und stelle mich unter die
dusche gibt es etwas was du regelmäßig
machst hast du gar nicht magst ja das
katzenklo nehme mir gefällt eigentlich
alles
also es gibt nichts was mir nicht
gefällt die geschirrspülmaschine
einräumen naja aber natürlich nein
natürlich nicht
ich räume jeden tag auf bisher zumindest
aufräumen also ich freue mich nicht
gerne auf den rechner anschalten und
arbeiten was machst du jeden abend kurz
vor dem einschlafen das licht aus mir
fällt dazu ein immer vor dem
schlafengehen putze ich mir die zähne
rausmachen lassen oder sonst gucken
ich gucke mir die nachrichten an
ich gucke aus dem fenster vor dem
schlafengehen schaue ich kurz aufs handy
ich vorm schlafengehen putz ich mir die
zähne
ich lese immer bevor ich ein schlag ich
denke daran was ich am tag gemacht habe
und dann schlafe ich ein
noch mal auf mein handy gucken und
nachrichten anschauen
als letztes am tag putzen der zähne
vielen dank und jetzt seid ihr dran wir
wollen von euch wissen was eure tägliche
routine ist was macht ihr als erstes am
morgen was macht ihr jeden tag was ihr
gar nicht mögt und was ist das letzte
was er macht bevor ihr schlafen geht
schreibt uns einen kommentar hier unten
unter unserem youtube video
und wenn ihr wissen wollt was wir den
ganzen tag so machen
dann folgt uns unbedingt auch auf
instagram und auch facebook besonders
auf instagram teilen wir auch immer
stories aus unserem täglichen leben und
dann seht ihr was bei easy german hinter
den kulissen passiert zum beispiel haben
wir diese woche unsere summer school
hier in berlin den link findet ihr unter
dem video
hier könnt ihr noch wie sie german
unterstützen und hier könnt ihr uns
abonnieren
bis nächste woche ciao
[Musik]